hey there everyone I'm Walter Bernays
Enoch I'm Heather Roose and I'm Liana
wave and this is top five doctor who has
been a cultural force throughout the
world for decades you know I've never
actually seen the show oh really
oh you're gonna love it obviously we
have to start you off with everyone's
favorite doctor guys guys cut it out we
can do both countdowns yeah but we
should do it numerically so Tenon's
first at the 10th doctor fair the first
episode of Doctor Who premiered on the
BBC in November of 1963 it ran from 1963
until 1989 then in 2005 the series was
revived and once again became a cult
classic in both Britain and America the
series still continues today every
season of the series focuses on the
doctor a Time Lord who travels through
time and space with his human companions
in his machine the TARDIS which looks
like a blue police box the Time Lords
are alien beings capable of regenerating
when injured this way the character of
the doctor has been portrayed by many
different actors throughout the years
each person adds their own Flair and
flavor to the Time Lord of Gallifrey
these are the top 5 best Tenth Doctor
episodes number 5
human nature / family of blood the
premise of this episode is actually
pretty simple oh thank god
yeah we're starting you off easy buddy
the doctor must completely transform
himself into a human in order to escape
a group of aliens called the family of
blood the family inhabits human hosts as
they attempt to find the doctor to suck
his energy so they can live forever it
would be easy to make this a throwaway
straightforward episode but doctor who
takes this simple base and elevates it
rather than focusing on the doctor being
a wacky fish out of water with the
humans the plot focuses on a development
that the doctor himself didn't think of
he falls in love with a human this
creates some amazing character
development as the human doctor named
John Smith must decide between becoming
the doctor to save the world or continue
living his human life with his love Joan
10 it creates some wonderful moments
with that conflict I'm John Smith that's
all I want to be John Smith with his
life his job a good man the doctor also
happens to land in England in 1913
meaning World War one is about to start
the next year the episodes then
integrate the theme of the ethics of war
especially since John Smith works at a
military boarding school for young boys
the story is compelling and interesting
with some really hard-hitting emotional
moments an unexpected Dimond of an
episode number four
the doctor's daughter the results are in
and doctor you are the father written by
Stephen greenhorn this episode touches
on Time Lord lore and the doctors
backstory it's also a great example of
the doctors relentless peacekeeping even
when vengeance seems more satisfying as
a transitional companion episode we get
to have Donna and Martha together in the
big blue box when the trio land on an
unfamiliar planet the doctor is forced
to have a tissue sample taken and
through some time-travel magic science
stuff the cell regeneration is sped up
to produce an adult clone named Jenny
this offspring creates some inner
turmoil for the doctor who likes to keep
his past carefully tucked away the
cloning process also sparks the
discussion of what qualifies as
parentage should she be considered the
doctor's daughter in addition to these
human clones they're mortal enemies
called the hath also inhabit this
society the hath are humanoid fish
beings and the two races have been
fighting for generations when Martha is
separated from the doctor and Donna
the trio must reunite without either
side slaughtering the other this
adventure shows how unlikely
relationships form and that fighting for
something doesn't have to mean resorting
to violence we don't have a choice for
Doctor Who fans this is possibly the
best episode for some geek out trivia
Jenny the doctor's daughter is played by
Georgia Moffett now Georgia Tennant as
she married David Tennant coincidentally
Georgia's father is Peter Davidson who
played the fifth doctor David and
Georgia have four children together as
well so in summation she is the doctor's
daughter who married the doctor from the
episode the doctor's daughter and also
gave birth to the doctor's daughter and
therefore granddaughter time is relative
after all I would absolutely love if
this legacy is teased again but either
way I love this little hidden detail
number three
the girl in the fireplace the doctor
always seems to run into beautiful and
important women throughout history and
this is no exception in this episode
written by Steven Moffat the doctor is
joined by his companion Rose we also get
the pleasure of having roses boyfriend
Mickey tag along as well this creates
some interesting relationship dynamics
for the doctors companion aboard a
presumably abandoned spaceship they
discover a portal to pre-revolutionary
France this fireplace is just one of a
few doorways into the life of a
historically fascinating young woman
unfortunately for this R Annette there
are terrifying monsters ticking away the
moments until she is ready for their
horrible plan I particularly love this
musical score to the episode but the
standout is definitely the design its
juxtaposition of a futuristic spaceship
and the opulence of Versailles is
outstanding these villains are also some
of the most memorable with their
elaborate waistcoats and terrifying
masks even their physicality of robotic
lumbering towards innocence with a sword
arm gives me the chills
there's something so ominous about a
monster breaking a clock so that it can
tick unnoticed under your bed there are
some great lines in this episode that
are classic David Tennant well about
dangerous
Nawal just have a quick scan guessing
them dangerous oh no you're not in the
hole okay you keep making oh who could
forget party mode doctor the doctor has
a way about saving children and we
really get a touch of how fleeting he
can be in someone's life while still
making such an impact Moffitt gives us
great comedy mixed into heartbreak and
this story is a great example of that
number two silence in the library slash
forest of the Dead the episode begins
but the doctor being called to the
largest library in the universe by
someone who turns out to be his wife
except he's never actually met her
before because they move through their
timelines in the opposite direction
so they keep this journal or they don't
understand anything right now sorry
about that little complicated one of the
things that makes these episodes great
is all the unexpected twists and turns
the doctor Donna and a team of
archaeologists are being hunted by
shadow monsters in the universe's
largest library however the episode
opens with a little girl seeing a
psychologist talking about the library
in her mind
now some spoilers we find out later in
the episode that the little girl is
actually Cal who is hooked into the
computer mainframe as a part of the
library she literally saved the
consciousness of everyone who was in the
library including Donna these people are
trapped in a fantasy world created by
cows mind until she freaks out and
begins a self-destruct sequence the
doctor is of course able to save the day
through some quick and clever thinking
perhaps the best part of the episodes
though is the introduction of one of my
favorite characters in the series River
Song
she and Tennant have undeniable
chemistry and worked perfectly together
she is spunky and independent she's able
to hold her own against a strong and
unpredictable character like the doctor
she struggles beautifully throughout the
episode coming to grips with this
version of the doctor not yet being the
doctor that she knows and loves their
emotional and complex episodes that
create some very iconic Doctor Who lines
hello sweetie
[Music]
in the number-one fest since dr. episode
is blink sticks and stones may break my
bones but angels will forever haunt me
how bad can angels be oh let's just say
you'll never look at statues the same
way again this episode was also written
by Steven Moffat guest starring Carey
Mulligan as Sally Sparrow and features
perhaps the most relatable line of
dialogue for Doctor Who fans I love all
the things they make me feel sad about
sad it's happy and deep at a property
that has had too many coincidental
disappearances Sally decides to explore
the house and find the convoluted tale
that centers around her mysteriously
shifting statues seem to be connected to
the occurrences of the missing persons
though separated by decades can Sally
help the doctor to keep these creatures
from claiming more victims interestingly
blink is rather sparse of the doctor and
his companion at the time Martha we see
some recordings of the doctor but don't
see him and Martha in action until
halfway through the episode my favorite
highlight is the meet-cute scene of
Sally's introduction to Billy one of the
only times I've ever shipped a couple so
immediately however the monsters debuted
in this episode are one of the most
terrifying villains the doctor faces
they are seemingly unstoppable and
vicious if you're intimidated by how
many seasons of Doctor Who there are
test the waters with this episode blink
is totally able to stand alone as there
isn't really continuity spill over since
the doctor and Martha aren't as featured
this story is really difficult to talk
about without spoiling a lot of the
twists and turns so I'll leave it to you
to watch and see for yourself but
remember not to blink
[Music]
we want to hear what you guys think
what's your favorite 10th doctor episode
what do you want to see us cover next on
the show leave a comment and let us know
to keep in touch you could like my
Facebook page or follow along on Twitter
and you can always talk Doctor Who with
me on Facebook Twitter or Instagram and
you can find me on Instagram Twitter or
twitch where I stream on Wednesday
nights we'll catch you back right here
next week with a brand new episode top 5
where we count down the top 5 best
episodes of my favorite doctor Matt
Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
you
now click never Blake hit wicket you